welcome to another episode of nacho deep
I'm your host grace and helping the
first we have Mike Falzone rhymes with
calzone he'll find that out on this
episode with us I am so thrilled he is
such a kind genuine saw a fellow East
Coaster that moved West to pursue comedy
and he's just got such a goddamn
precious wonderful optimistic outlook on
life and I'm so thrilled that he was
here also his hair just is like pretty
and bouncy and healthy and curly and
nice we don't talk about it at all just
know that I was thinking it the whole
time enjoy this very exciting episode
with Mike Falzone this episode of not
too deep is brought to you by you won't
believe it but it's Squarespace turn
your great idea into reality with
Squarespace they make it easier than
ever to launch your passion project
you're gonna showcase some word you want
to sell some products of any kind
they got beautiful templates for you and
the ability to customize just about
anything so you can make a beautiful
website all by yourself super simple
super easy but if you do get stuck which
is no shame on you they have 24/7
award-winning customer support that is
there to help so head to Squarespace
comm such grace for a free trial and
when you're ready to lunch use the offer
code grace to get 10% off your first
purchase of a website or doing micro
zone is here hello hello I'm very
excited saying the king of podcasts you
have to it's the least amount of podcast
I've ever had wait how many more have
you had in the past no I used to be on
the SourceFed 1 all the time right right
and the one with welcome to our podcast
when me and Zoe and dynamic bantorra
means right and so ok you weren't were
you part of SourceFed or were you just
like giving them free work not free oh
that's good not free but also I told
them that I wouldn't be like full-time
but guy in it towards the end almost
like I'll be here as much as you want me
to be here gotcha gotcha gotcha yeah how
do you because you also do your YouTube
channel where it's kind
like ruminations and thoughts on life
and things and observations about stuff
do you ever get tired of talking and you
stand up and do all these things that
are like how does he consistently have
something to say my child I've had
something to say for as long as I've
been able to say you prepared your whole
life for this career that you're in
right now I didn't a lot of people don't
know this I didn't talk for the first
fourteen years of my life completely
terrified I don't know what my voice
sound oh my god okay but I want to go
back through cuz I was like going
through your history of everything and I
forgot a lot of things that you've
started on YouTube in 2006 6 January
June you remember the day yeah how did
you do this January 2012 days a year
yeah I exist for 12 days a year and then
they get older so how did you find
YouTube I was a musician right cuz you
started doing music yeah yeah and so I'm
kind of or we are kind of of the
generation where it's like if you make
something and you want to get it out to
as many people as possible the the
internet was a very like new and
accessible thing so I had music on like
mp3.com and MySpace yeah and when
YouTube popped up it was just like
another smart place to to put stuff
really so but in 2006 like I didn't know
about it until oh seven oh eight ish
yeah but I didn't even understand what
it was yeah I mean that's another good
part of being an only child it's like
something new pops up on the Internet
essentially man and I didn't know what I
was doing on it for a long time but then
you know like anything else you find
what you like doing
or one thing hits it big and then you
repeat that over and over again until no
one gives sort of
yeah I mean luckily it hasn't been I've
never hated it like I've been super
exhausted and fried yeah
I've hated other things about it sure
years but I've never hated what I've
done because I always kind of do what I
want and I try to make it um useful ya
know that's super smart and I was like
what was the move from music to comedy
for you when did that happen it was
basically I played music so many days a
year for so long because that's what you
had to I was like a like I'm working
harder instead of working smarter type
person yeah so I kind of burnt myself
out on music and then eventually it's
like I would be playing this B songs
either with a band or by myself and I
would I would love making people laugh
either daring or in between the songs
more than I liked the process of writing
and playing the slash so then it was
just like a very yeah yeah yeah when did
you start doing stand-up mm 7 or 8 Wow
okay yeah but I was in Connecticut so I
couldn't do like that every night three
times a night every know the full
[ __ ] hustle everyone does out here
the I still have never done stand-up cuz
it terrifies me mmm that's not that bad
mmm I've seen let's get me in my lane
what was the thing that finally like
made you go up on stage and do stand-up
um I don't know I I think it was because
eventually what I was doing in between
my songs was like the crowd work stuff
yeah and then um I always just didn't
think I was smart enough to write jokes
like peers were writing jokes quotation
fingers want to say I've been friends
with um with Andrew Santino for a long
time yeah and he was always like you
know like I was the internet guy and he
was the stand-up guy and I always had so
much admiration for what he did and then
I would see certain people who got up on
stage and talked to the audience like I
talk and laugh with my friends like um
Chris D'Elia was a was a person that
makes his audience laugh
almost the exact way me and my friends
make each other laugh and I was like oh
I could figure out like my way to do
that
Benham I'm say yes this is where like
you know it they say it takes you 10 to
15 years to find your voice so I've
never regretted any of the music stuff I
still miss it from time to time but that
was like the journey of me finding my
voice in standup
did you ever have because I had this
like real push pull struggle ish
situation because I did improv and like
YouTube was like my secret you know
guilty thing yeah that liked being taken
seriously in like the actual comedy
world that like it's I don't know why I
had and still feel kind of embarrassed
like talking to YouTube to like people
that do stand-up every night because
everyone has such a negative opinion
about cuz there's so much horseshit yeah
on the internet and people blow up from
from doing horseshit and that's fine
because it's it's fun if it entertains
your audience it's not a bad thing but
people get um you know how comedians are
they hold everything high standard yeah
like oh if you're on the internet where
all these other people are you must be
one of them yeah no one gives a [ __ ]
about your struggle or mm-hmm
what you've done to to make your way but
then like I'm lucky enough now that
people see you do it over and over again
and they're like oh you're one of us
yeah but I worked very hard for that oh
ya know and people don't realize that
yeah ya know and then there's also like
the counter to that too is that they're
stand-ups that suck up comedian you can
also be like that's not that impressive
either cuz a lot of people know but way
Porter but I also do you t okay so you
have this crowd work show which is nuts
to me because not only are you doing
stand-up which is terrifying but you're
also now going up without any actual it
rehearse jokes and you're talking to
people in the audience and just speaking
of things that a lot of people have
respect for but it must be meditative
cause you to be so present in
moment and like really connect with
people or completely disconnect with
people that are fully disconnected have
there been any standout insane moments
of having to do this I think just the
fact that I get to do it and it's such
like it's become such a popular thing
and like and you're so good at my thanks
which is like a muscle but I don't think
people realize is like hard to flex yeah
well a lot of like traditional stand-up
people talk about a [ __ ] about crowd
work because it's not crafting a joke
which is art and a puzzle that you're
always putting guys yeah but it's also
like you know I'm 34 I don't give a [ __ ]
about still around as soon as my wife
leaves me because I'm a bad comedian but
I'll start to evaluate my chef yeah but
it really is just this thing that like
it's from music it's from dude I used to
I always go back to I used to play music
at this place in Fairfield Connecticut
called the chef's table and the owner
his name was rich he used to let me get
up for like three or four hours at a
time from like lunch to dinner when
people would be coming in and out of
this deli and I used to just be in the
corner or whatever and no one gave a
[ __ ] I was just background noise you
know and I'm playing you know my cry cry
song is about why girls don't like the
only way to keep people engaged and to
let them know who you are was to like
talk to them and make them laughing so
it's just like literally there was one
year where I looked back at my MySpace
page oh yeah and I was having like 250
shows a year where most of them would be
like you know I take my college courses
uh-huh Fairfield University which was
down the street and I walk with my
guitar and I'd sit in the corner of this
deli and play for like four hours you're
a beatnik yeah I could never find the
right hat but it's my favorite thing and
I think especially now with like there's
nothing wrong with any style of stand-up
if you're making people happy now in
2019 where everyone's all [ __ ] bummed
out about everything all the time you're
doing a great job but um I think that
everything is so scripted and polished
like even reality TV is something yeah
that I think people really get a lot out
of going to a paying for a ticket and
you go to a place and you know that
that's never gonna happen again
yeah and so I love being able to give
people that also it's kind of terrifying
as an audience member you know you're
walking into a lion's den where you are
fair game for all these comedians that
are coming up they're like I don't know
had I not known you would ever want to
go to one show but that's another thing
is like people inherently think it's
like a negative roasty thing and it
definitely our show was like rarely that
yeah because it's not dealing with a
heckler no it's trying to make something
out of a conversation hmm dude I was
like I have this show that I do every
Tuesday I'm lucky enough to be able to
drop in on the show called heavy heavy
low low it's at bar Lubitsch okay West
Hollywood and it starts at 11 o'clock at
night and there's rarely more than like
eight people that yeah yeah and I had
four hecklers last night so half the
crowd was yeah yeah I think two of more
in the bathroom at the time so 75% of
the crowd is hecklers so dealing with
them is completely different than trying
to give someone an enjoyable experience
like yeah the idea that they're on a
weekday night spending their time trying
to cut you down
yeah like pursuing art is like so
inherently sad it was I had so much fun
man oh yeah they destroyed like the
first comic that one up my buddy Tommy
goes they were they individual are they
working together Wheatley individual and
this is a real thing there was a guy the
first guy shouting everybody out was
named Chad and he was just as white as
you could be yeah he looked like a cloud
with a beard and he had a button-up like
bro finance sure sure and he was
obviously sitting like that
yeah just fully manspreading he was open
yeah and then he ended up by the end of
the conversation to find out everything
I could about him and like obviously the
conversation went to his trust fund at
one
are you serious and so he was just like
dude somebody put you here oh you know
like you got cast for this
you're the most la douchebag I've ever
heard yeah and he's trying to like ruin
these art for these poor comedians
trying to get better at 11:30 at night
oh my god and then there was another
woman who was like I don't need to be
here I'm a writer and she was like
wasted and very like about herself which
is very popular self-important yeah and
at one point I was like what are you
right you know I'm trying to mine stuff
and she's like I don't need to give you
my whole resume and I was like okay then
you're done and then at one point she
was like oh can't handle talking to a
strong independent woman huh and by this
point I was like I don't know if you've
met my wife I assume that you have but
she is Albanian do you know any Albanian
people and then like got me on this
whole make a lot of assumptions Oh a
hundred percent yeah it must be fun like
you're giving people almost by accident
therapy sessions yeah they'll give you
some [ __ ] for sure
oh I'm sure yeah is there because you
travel you're on the road a lot too and
you do shows is there a particular spot
in that you've traveled to that's like
perfect for you your stand-up um I
really don't know we I've had really
good experiences I haven't had any bad
experiences especially with the crowd
work show and I mean doing the mixture
of crowd work and and written material
so you can kind of if people are there
to have a good time I can kind of make
any show the vibe that I want it to be
by mixing those two things but you guys
weren't you just in Nashville yeah you
and Steve did dynamic banter down there
looks awesome it was so cool how is that
doing the podcast live I think it's
great it's just talking to Steve just
like an audience listening to I was
listening to your most recent episode on
the way over it's just like being
allowed in on a friendship conversation
yeah yeah it's really sweet and it's the
same thing going back to the crystal Lea
thing it's like I laugh
with Steve like I used to laugh with my
friends from back home and like moving
out here and you know how it is you
start your whole life over especially
coming from the East Coast it's like
completely different group of people
totally so if you find someone you could
just be like totally stupid silly with
and then you could somehow monetize
really like I lived the dream with
everyone from here that I'd like that I
do stuff with Bob work shows living the
dream being able to do this stuff with
Steve and laugh like little kids yeah
this is [ __ ] awesome oh no that's so
so fun ok let's talk about zoya your
wife hell yeah strong independent
albanian woman yeah how did you guys
meet each other she came to a show oh
really in Connecticut when I was still
doing a mixture of music and comedy I
was doing these question jar shows okay
got inspiration from that from a guy
named Mike Dodi who used to you know he
he is an awesome songwriter and then he
would have this question jar and he'd
reach into it and answer anonymous
questions and I was already doing that
on the Internet yeah so I was like might
as well do it here and she had just been
through like a really bad breakup and
her friends dragged her out and they
were like you got to come see this guy
he's so good-looking so and she was
dragged there by a bunch of her friends
and and I saw her and I was like she's
like stupid cute and I was in
Connecticut and I was like but I know
everyone here I've never seen his face
you know he gets a small town so she
came out and then she was just real cool
about it and then I found her on on
Facebook afterwards and then I asked her
out on a date to a Starbucks oh that's
so cute yeah yeah and then cuz Starbucks
is the fancy place yeah oh yeah and then
she there were two Starbucks's one is a
standalone building in the parking lot
of the mall yes and then one is a kiosk
inside the target in the mall these both
make sense yeah yep so she went to the
kiosk and I went to the stand alone and
she was like I'm here like
I don't have a lot of time what are you
doing and I was like where are you she's
like I'm in the target and I said do you
think I asked you to a kiosk she was
nervous and I was nervous and it was it
was nice and then I [ __ ] it up a bunch
of times and now we're married and now
you're married yeah I mean it's a modern
romance yeah yeah oh my god but I also
you know wouldn't put it past you know
someone inviting you to a kiosk
maybe we'll splurge on some ray-bans to
be cool I actually need some vacuum
cleaner bags so if you wanna maybe make
out after that we're gonna take a quick
break on this height of romance when we
get back more with Mike Falzone oh not
too deep we'll be right back guess what
yep you guessed it this episode of Notre
Dame is sponsored by our dear dear
friends over at Squarespace turn your
dream into a reality with Squarespace
they make it easier than ever to launch
your passion project look if you want to
build a website if you want to start a
new business you want to showcase work
you want to publish content sell
products they are the tool for you they
have beautiful templates world-class
designers have helped build them and
they have the ability for you to
customize just about anything with a few
clicks and you can make a beautiful
website all by yourself but if you are a
little like wary or unsure they have
award-winning customer service that's
24/7 that you can head up I mean buying
their domains as simple everything is
optimized from over right out of the box
there's nothing to patch or upgrade ever
and they have a powerful ecommerce
functionality so lets you sell anything
online and they have analytics that help
you grow in real time so if you are at
all interested in any of the above go to
squarespace.com slash grace for a free
trial and when you are ready to launch
use the offer code grace to save 10% of
your first purchase of a website
domaine web sort web sort I mean maybe
that's available as a domain name a
website or domain that squarespace.com
slash grace offer code grace are you
looking for fits / a shin getting fit
and staying healthy has never been
easier than with open fit open fit is a
brand-new super simple streaming service
that allows you to work out from the
comfort of your own living room in as
little as 10 minutes a day open fit is
great for all fitness levels plus it's
affordable and accessible you view on
your computer web enabled TV tablet
smartphone or even a Roku and you know
one of my favorite hobbies includes not
being in the physical presence of others
let alone to workout so this is an
optimum system for me open fit has
changed the way I workout and by texting
my code grace you're a ce2 30 30 30 you
can join me on a fitness journey
personalized just for you right now
during the open fit 30-day challenge my
listeners get a special extended 30-day
free trial membership to open fit again
when you text grace to 30 30 30 you will
get full access to open fit all the
workouts and nutrition information
totally free again just text grace to 30
30 30 standard message and data rates
may apply okay we're back let's talk
about wrestling just sweetly so kindly
gifted me these collectible wrestling
cards and an ultimate warrior pin and
it's I'm so glad to be able to talk with
someone else that is a sincere wrestling
fan and we've never really talked about
last night yeah I've fallen off a little
bit like going to Wrestlemania this year
I felt a little bit like a poser because
I was trained like furiously scrambled
to figure out what all the storylines
were never happening there's so much
there's a lot going on yeah but you've
your whole life wrestling fan for the
most part I fell off a little bit in
like after high school like you were
busy playing music I was so busy I'll
say busy get my heart all broke up
rhyming words
um but like 1988-89 when I was like
super low boy yeah
I would get these like VHS tapes um guys
that my dad plays softball way and so
I've probably watched SummerSlam 88
10,000 laps and then like 91 92 it would
be like what I did on Saturday morning
yeah even like I remember I had this TV
in my room cuz I would my parents would
go on and off from like letting me watch
it or not yeah and 91 92 was like super
cartoony and was like made up or like a
like a occupational wrestler like a cop
and so I was super into it I had this
little black and white TV in my room
with bunny ears now it I would try to
get it and then the Attitude Era at the
end of the 90s and early 2000s it was
you know that's when kind of everyone
liked it and then it got like real gross
Oh kind of fell off yeah I got real like
graphic and yeah blood everywhere blood
and titties pretty much oh yeah it was
most of it and there was a lot of like
it just felt like a key--and weird after
a while yeah and so I kind of fell off
and then I came back to it and it's just
a lot like every show they have is like
three hours that's the thing I record
them and then I speed through I feel
like my sparknotes version of it from
time to time yeah like going to the
shows it's [ __ ] nuts
yeah say it it's like my I say my
favorite form of theater it's like if
you go to the Renaissance Faire or if
you go to medieval times it's the same
thing everyone is the most joyous and
like the most like this is where we all
belong environment about is comfortable
for the first time that's why I always
get so [ __ ] up when people are like um
when people have so much [ __ ] to talk
about it but they are really into Star
Wars and shape like I've had so many
people talk down to me
that's a cinematic adventure that spans
generations tell me about it there's a
bad guy and a good guy
and they're fighting and then they're
always they do it live or they take
27000 taste to do it's just so funny
what people choose to be like you know
and I'm no different man I I am you know
I've made friends cry over their love
for Harry Potter
okay do you follow it now currently I I
mean not i don't watch every show sure
but like I'll try to if there's a
pay-per-view on yeah I really like to
watch that what I do more than anything
is like I'll be working at my house and
all these really important internet
things that I'm doing you know have the
network going on in the back yeah and
I'll have all the primetime wrestling
which is like Bobby Heenan and Gorilla
Monsoon and they're like late night show
talking about wrestling or I'll watch
the stuff like wrestling superstars that
used to be on Saturday mornings like
I'll watch all that [ __ ] and I'll just
have a completely different experience
than when I was like seven now 34 and
watching the [ __ ] that I did when I was
seven like episodically it's just
fascinating on a thousand level yeah but
you also did so you worked for The
Rock's Channel yeah for a little while
yeah you did wrestling Fred yeah okay
tell us about this cuz as a kid that
grew up on wrestling this must have been
weird and wonderful and also weird
it was mostly weird but it's also like
crazy career highlight yeah you know so
I was with Syrio 71 at the time and they
had just signed the Rock The Rock and
should make his channel to build him up
as a youtube channel yeah yeah should we
explain who the rock is should we catch
everybody
what are you living under a hand so I
didn't like that I said that that was a
corny I'll probably never say it I'll
probably say it tonight so they have
this they set up this thing for him that
was like a promo tournament called Rock
the promo okay and it was like you could
submit all these things and you submit
yourself as a fake wrestler and you give
a promo and then if you make it they
pick you
you're basically entered into like a
sweet 16 tournament we can cut promos
against other people doing the same
thing March Madness for yes 100% people
who are not in shape people always
wanted to be so I had been doing this
wrestling fred thing on the internet for
a long time I used to do this character
on my channel called oh hey Batman and
his kind of Batman but nah I wore a
Batman mask and I acted like the dumbest
version of Batman and then a new Batman
movie came out and it was like then
everyone started doing that so I'm like
I'm out yeah but I used to love doing
the character so much and it was just
barely Batman so I changed that to a
wrestler I'm like why haven't I done a
wrestling thing I'm in love with it my
whole life
uh-huh so I found this mask on these
gloves and I named this person and I was
doing this and then I kind of you know
it runs its course and then I kind of
fell out of doing it then this
tournament popped up and I was like Oh
Fred's gonna be in the tournament sure
he'll show up so they ended up liking it
uh-huh and I you know battled all these
people and I did the whole reality show
thing of like you know you record this
stuff from your house and they give you
a prompt and you do it and it was really
really fun and I made it to like the
semi-finals and then I got voted out by
I think Mick Foley voted me out and he
was like it seems like you're trying to
be a wrestler but you're not a real
wrestler and I'm like hey Mick do you
understand yeah but so I lost in the
tournament the producers of the show
loved the character so much and thought
it was so unique yeah that um they
invited me back for the finale which
took place in Vegas so the finale was
like you do your
live at the other you know the two
finalists and the rock is there and he's
like officiating though oh my god him in
Joe Santiago do you know him no who's
that
he's a youtube person from New York but
he's very funny okay Italian kid he
reminds me a lot of my friends growing
up so he was like the host of the whole
tournament okay and then the rock comes
in and then they brought me back in it's
like a run in to like roast the two
finalists and then leave so I did that
and it was like the highlight of my
career and I'm like dude there's no
stakes you know cuz I'm not winning in
anything anything anyway I mean the rock
introduces me as like before I pick a
winner I'm gonna my friends gonna come
in and he's gonna tell you what he
thinks so I'm like being brought in as
this fake carrot like wrestling flag has
been flown that sounds like he's
introducing a more famous person yeah I
could say anything rustling Fred has to
give us his two cents and let me allowed
to speak you know so I'm like going over
what I'm gonna say and I come in and I
roast these two people and I struggle to
get in and out of the ropes and I do
this whole bit and then I meet him
afterwards dude a thing about the rock
is like you know you see him on all his
Instagram things and he's like shaking
hands with people or whatever but he's
really like that oh yeah and he saw me
in the corner of the room and he was
like Fred do you want a picture and I
got my mask on cuz I'm in character I'm
not gonna break kayfabe just cuz the
rock is here they're not so uh so we
take a picture and you know he's like
the whole time from the second he got
there like we rehearsed it like we were
a pit crew like we're gonna come in and
we're gonna do this from 15 minutes and
then he's out he has to go pee on a jet
to somewhere else so we did that and it
was so efficient and his like handler is
like you we gotta go we gotta go and
he's staying to like do little videos
and pictures with everyone it's [ __ ]
awesome yeah so then the contest ended
and then the producers and the the
writers of the show were like do you
want to like be on the rocks Channel
as this dude so we shot like four or
five episodes of this thing which the
audience liked they liked Fred from the
the contest but the walk himself wasn't
involved in every episode right so the
views kind of went down a little bit and
then they had to get rid of me after
that but I was able to do something with
Pauly Shore which was a huge thing
because I had been watching Pauly Shore
all my life like MTV and the movie
son-in-law I went to Blockbuster a
thousand times and and also like his mom
is obviously mitzi and she opened the
comedy store so that was a huge fun
thing and it was just awesome to be like
like the rock is our generation actor
ever and he's just like a Renaissance
man
yeah he has so many different like
passions and he does it and he like kind
of the thing that I really like he was a
guest on the show that I did years ago
and it was the same thing he came and he
introduced himself to every single crew
member everyone he literally had like a
hard out and like we had no air
conditioning and he's sweating like
crazy but he's not complaining a bit
about anything he's being so dry out
here hahaha literally pouring sweat down
his face and like any other like a less
actor would be like I can't do this I
don't look good on camera she's like so
just like grateful and gracious in this
way that you're like no you're not
allowed to be grateful I'm grateful that
you're here stop out like gratitude in
me right now he knows he doesn't it's
like it's raining on a statue but it's a
lot like you know from WWE to like
actually mainstream acting like YouTube
to do in comedy kind of thing that it's
like he doesn't he's he's proud of his
whole career in the WWE and it's like
given him the platform to jump to other
things and yeah I'm just like always
inspired by that that I'm like yeah yeah
I should be proud of the things I've
done I mean that's what I like about to
be totally honest like we've never we've
known I've known about you fir'd ever
yeah but we've never really hung out we
run into each other at like a VidCon
yeah but we've never like really hung
out outside of like a VidCon party or
whatever and when we started like
hanging out like a friendship capacity I
was like man I hope she's cool the
things that you instantly as soon as you
have like a conversation about work yeah
you recognize the people who work really
hard and I was like oh dude she [ __ ]
she [ __ ] yes well that's I mean I had
the same conversation with Joe Bereta
when he was on here that I was like this
is the first time we're actually like
talking about anything and we share a
lot of similar points of view about the
engine like I respect you very much yes
is very nice and sweet dude another
thing is we were so you should know that
like the hard working YouTube community
mm-hmm
was so proud of you for the ething Oh
like we was like oh she [ __ ] that was
like they kicking the door open
it was very sweet it was a weird time
but it was very sweet
oh I get it and you know some things
work some things don't I'm championing
Lilly Singh now I might get a girl like
continue this like yeah I'm merging of
both sides of everything but yeah I'm I
mean what's the rock gonna do next well
happily go back to YouTube I mean I'm
not I can't speak for okay we're friends
always think about what my I have a
loose idea of if I ever did WWE as like
my retirement plan which is unfathomable
because I realize that all the women in
WWE are like max
26 years old you know I'm fully out of
that age but I would be The Hangover and
I'd come down just totally hungover wear
sweatpants not be good at wrestling and
really make those women that are
absolutely fantastic athletes shine even
more smart I mean if they need me it's a
great humor I'll be here I'll go here on
waiting around for the second Attitude
Era hold me back get these kids out of
here and I'll show you back
um how did you get your mic in the
morning Mike made the mic flag yeah
there's a place in Connecticut but
they're too expensive for sure and so I
would shout them out but they're like
real as die-cut like a fancy state it's
very impressive it's my favorite thing
that I have I have a replica
championship belt that Zoey gave me that
I had to win and I have a microphone
flag that says Mike in the morning I'm
doing Mike in the morning for now couple
years man I thought like that was one of
those things where it's like I was given
this from the time that I was in
Connecticut to when I moved you know a
couple years into being in LA I was
doing this this thing where I would give
advice to people and I've kind of gone
back to that yeah but it got very heavy
for a while mm-hmm and I was like I
started giving this like good and funny
life advice after having a couple like
really bad health scares and like
knowing if I was gonna come out of the
hospital and stuff like that so I have
this new lease on life and I made a
promise to myself that I would never
talk about [ __ ] that I don't know about
obviously because you shouldn't do that
yeah so I was like anything that I've
done in my 20s or teens that I have any
kind of take away from where I could
give this knowledge to somebody else to
just save them a little bit of time yeah
that's my purpose cuz I was like when
I'm when I was in the hospital I was
like oh I could legitimately not come
out of this building so time becomes the
most important thing that you have Wow
so if I could save other people time by
being like off someone's treating you
like that that means this ends this and
this and [ __ ] them and on to the next
and I just wanted to give that to a
younger generation of people I still
want to do that I think that's great cuz
it's it's it's packaged in a very funny
way but then when you actually unwrap
what you're saying it's very sincere
advice to people which I think it caught
me off guard a little bit when I was
like watching a bunch of them recently
that I was like oh no this is actually
great advice even though it's hilarious
the way that you're presenting it but
it's like no this is genuine this is
really cool I think thank you for saying
that
yeah I think that's the thing that makes
it valuable at all like obviously like
even my view
have gone like way way down but I think
the people who are who are watching and
like I think they get it and I think
they get a lot out of it and that's all
I ever wanted it's not for everybody
no and it's because you don't want 15
million views on something that no one
cares about oh yeah right right I'm sure
because that's the cool thing when I saw
you and Elliot do shows in Boston and I
was like this room of people that are
here to watch you guys it's so warm and
engaged with you like this is what you
want you don't want to sell out a 3,000
seat theater with people that are like
what who is this why am I here yeah it's
just like one a wonderful group of
people that just like really want to
hear and are like phone's off I'm here
present with these people because I care
about them but I mean that's another
part of like earning your place in the
stand-up community is like trying to
kill in front of audiences that don't
give a [ __ ] about you or your following
or your YouTube presence and and that's
where you you earn your spot I think and
I'm very proud of that as well two
completely different experiences is okay
because the most recent one that I
watched this episode we'll go up way
later but was the when someone says I
love you and like three things not to
say when someone says I love you if
you're not prepared to say it back yeah
and you mentioned Zoi your wife in that
do you and don't have doesn't say has
there been a decision collectively of
like how much of your personal life
you're allowed to share your own podcast
- yeah yeah we just kind of have common
sense about it you respect each other
yeah yeah yeah yeah and also very like I
don't know I we don't really look at it
in any specific way really we just
thought whatever comes out yeah you know
that you trust each other enough to not
say too much or not make the other
person look terrible yeah yeah yeah and
the thing is like even if she said
something to make me look terrible like
she's the realest person I know yeah so
I'm like either I deserve it
or like it'll be at the very least it'll
be a very genuine conversation yeah yeah
like an eye-opening experience yeah like
okay this is a learning moment yeah this
is a teaching moment why should I be the
only one not learning
okay speaking of all of these wonderful
people that love you we're gonna take a
quick break when we get back we have so
many Twitter questions for you if you do
not mind answering those for us well you
know where to be until 11:30
[Music]
Wow
thank you me for throwing to me to give
you guys a break from listening to all
that blah blah blah so that I could tell
you about Bud Light shilada are you
craving flavor and refreshment this
summer pick up one of the three flavors
of Bud Light colada we got original
extra lime and the newest member of the
family mango Bud Light chill out is
perfect for drinking at brunch on the
beach or just hanging out with friends
in the sunshine the original gelato
brings you the crisp refreshing taste of
Bud Light with the rich signature taste
of a Clamato tomato cocktail this
distinctive blend delivers a flavor that
truly refreshes then you got the chill
lotta extra lime which delivers a
tropical citrusy spin on the classic
gelato flavor sorry I got so tongue-tied
because my mouth is watering and then
you got the newest member of the family
chill out a mango
Oh at a tropical touch of summertime to
your flavor profile and you know it's
best to enjoy your chill Atta gently
rotate the chilled can once before
pouring then pour over ice and garnish
with a slice of lime some celery or
mango salt the rim of your glass at a
dash of hot sauce for even more kick and
there you go now you're a very
experienced bartender and no one will
know the difference
pick up a Bud Light chill out of today
and learn more at Bud Light Calm go to
Bud Light dot-com
but like shilada flavor that refreshes
this episode of nutty deepers brought to
you by a company that not only do I love
saying out loud as
a supportive company of this podcast but
also I think that they will provide a
product for you that you will love it's
aunt Fanny's you heard it right aunt
Fanny's for years we've been told that
clean meant one thing sanitized it's
supposed to be healthy but sanitizers
and disinfectants wipe out everything
all the good healthy stuff along with
any of the bad so like your gut turns
out your home has a microbiome too and
research is starting to show that this
like kilomole approach may be going too
far with negative effects on our health
and especially for kids now aunt Fanny's
brings probiotics to your home and your
hands with their new microcosmic line
you heard that correctly I think micro
cosmic line these household cleansers
and hand soaps add good with probiotic
power each has an extract of beneficial
bacteria plus super effective
plant-based ingredients to be tough
enough on dirt and gentle on you these
formulas are non-toxic cruelty-free and
have 100% essential oil scent so there's
no fake fragment for it frake fragrance
there's note there's none of it no fake
fragrances here they're hypoallergenic
and dermatologist tested too so what are
you waiting for why stop at just natural
cleaning when you can do one better with
probiotics shop now at aunt Fanny's calm
lush good and get 20% off your entire
order with coupon code grace grac at
checkout again because I love saying it
out loud that's aunt Fanny's calm / good
coupon code grace my cow zone
I'm increase told to tell you that
that's how the correct pronunciation of
your name yes you know you're funnier
than that I know I'm funnier than my
calzone gadem
okay because it sounds like calzone
Falzone are you wait is this a genuine
epiphany for you right no but I like
okay before we get into these sort of
questions when I asked you the two
questions asked every single guest
that's on the podcast and the first is
who alive or dead would you most want to
throw cold spaghetti at yeah I know how
long do people normally take to answer
this it varies sometimes people don't
come up with an answer because they take
it very seriously I think I'm doing that
so is this somebody that like you don't
like it's entirely up to you you're the
master of your own intention okay so
check this out okay when I was a baby my
dad I was sleeping and my dad for
whatever reason dropped a cold wet towel
on my stomach no no no no no but I hear
the story every time I go home like it
just happened in there trying to Vermont
like never forget type thing so that
happened my mom got very upset and
obviously I woke up crying and she was
like why did you do that my dad like Oh
what dude just doing walking around with
a cold wet towel well he's a father you
have them it's a preparedness yeah so I
think I would like to go home and wait
until my dad is fast asleep in his
recliner and the Mets are on TV and then
I'm gonna pull up his little shirt I
don't want to just drop
[Laughter]
Oh God that yeah I mean it's a sweet
retaliation so many years later yeah oh
man I love that okay the other question
is to tell us your worst pants shooting
story or a close call but you can only
use three words or small phrases so for
instance mine is college jogging front
lawn buffalo chicken drive fast gastic
[Music]
[Music]
okay that's going to Twitter questions
some on Eric wants to know do you miss
making music yeah very recently really
do you what do you know Tessa violet
yeah we've been friends for a long time
so she's coming into her own us like
this she's an amazing her in DoDEA
Victoria yeah yeah so I'll go see her
when she's in town I'll go see her
perform and just like she opened up for
this man call coin recently okay I
didn't know him either but apparently
they're they're real popular well but
she's just like playing electric guitar
with her awesome band she had this
amazing drummer yeah and in front of
this massive group of people jumping up
and down simultaneously and I was like
oh I remember that that feeling but I
had so much like I was the dude in the
band who wanted to make it and my two
friends were just like stoked to play
music and they were very much like one
worked in a bank one works in
construction so I was like the dude and
I was always like more stressed out and
working hard and then like we would have
fun intermittently right right but I
missed like being loud with my friends
in New York City at like 1 o'clock in
the morning we were ready to keep doing
this yeah mr. Hollywood over here yeah
man um someone to know do you agree that
Zoya is more famous than you are I would
say if we're being honest she's not
[Laughter]
but she is better than me in every other
way bein famous is not conducive to
being better than someone as we've seen
but she is she's a better more real more
dude the thing about Zoya that I admire
the most out of any her work ethic or
anything is the fact that like her good
person
radar is like incise to think that I was
the best judge of character and I'm very
good yeah but she is like it's insane
yeah it's insane you know those basic
white girls who are like my gaiter she's
like what they think they are
yeah no that's totally fair and I've I
can tell that in her for short that I
think you guys are both just sugar to
the core like at the end of the day just
real actual humans yeah so she's better
but I'm more famous for sure okay social
media numbers which is the only measure
of value in the human society that we
live and currently check the numbers I
mean look at the numbers please someone
said daft humor says how much do you
miss SourceFed I miss it every day I
miss
I um I felt worse for the people who
when that whole thing ended yeah I felt
worse for the people who woke up and
watch that every day cuz I get that yeah
and like I had when I was having fun
there I had so much fun there and you
know we made everything our own and we
you know we tweaked some stuff and
obviously there was a whole group of
people who hated it because it wasn't
the original for yeah but then the group
of people who was there at the end
[ __ ] loved each other and and watched
out for each other and was like there
was no vindictiveness at all like
everyone was [ __ ] you know holding
each other up and supporting each other
and like all this [ __ ] but it wasn't
always like that and and the audience
was so good to all of us yeah and so
when we got fired it was like it almost
like wasn't even like what was us
because everyone's talented enough in
whatever they do to find a different job
or whatever yeah but I felt bad for the
people who maybe felt like not
marginalized but just felt like um they
relied on this thing every day
yeah all sudden this thing left yeah
nowhere and then they're like wait a
minute I trusted you guys to be
consistent in my life yeah I know you're
not here how yeah yeah yeah like we
can't we don't have control of this
because some dude didn't think it was a
viable but the cool thing is you guys
all built genuine friendships out of it
and you saw work together consistently
and you things like dynamic banter and
stuff like that that like live on and
breathe outside of this ecosystem that
you guys were all kind of this biodome
that you guys were all in for a little
bit yeah and everything good ends and I
don't know who would still be there if
we were still doing it every day and so
sometimes it's good and in like
spectacular fashion like you know it
went out and this really weird sad yeah
tone and then like think about there
would never be a sugar pine seven if
there wasn't a you know and so many
people love that yeah and um you know
same thing with the valley folk and and
all that ya know it evolved mm-hmm let's
just say it's like a [ __ ] Pokemon
yeah whatever they do when they change
into the other one that goes you know
how the pocket men do yeah the pokey
women know what initially sparked his
interest to start stand-up um being
enamored by stand-up and and the
challenge of like I never thought I was
smart enough to do it like I was saying
before it's like dude I've been watching
stand up and like VHS tapes that my dad
had you know taped off of HBO forever
and it like Rodney Dangerfield used to
have this like variety stand-up show on
HBO that I've watched so many episodes
of and like comic relief and watching
George Carlin and Richard Pryor and I
was like those people are just like
different yeah and in reality they're
just grown-ups who pay attention and
have their their very
you know their core belief system and
they have a point of unions on things a
point of view a very strong clear point
of view yeah and I was like oh I'm never
gonna be that and then like you almost
died a couple times and then you get
that yeah like I have some stuff to say
like more than anything to be especially
on the internet like everyone gets so
sad and doomsday about Chef yeah I think
the world is dying and bla bla bla bla
bla and all this sad horseshit let
people dump into the world and like this
echo chamber of sadness and then just
very simply to remove a guitar and to
remove any shields between you and the
audience and to just be a person with a
thing that makes your voice louder
making a roomful of people happy yeah
there's nothing in the world that's
better
total joy yeah total total joy and also
connecting with someone that also goes
haha in a way that's like currency of
yes I agree I also have that point of
view or I didn't realize that I have
that point of view that you have or an
observation that you had is just like
magical do to even with like and I don't
get super into this and it's another as
a result of like not being smart enough
and not being like um as aware as I
should be but I have one or two I think
really clever jokes about like race
relations and especially like a couple
years ago I mean it's always kind of it
always is what it is but a couple years
ago when things were getting like really
really bad to be able to say these jokes
and then to be approached by like a
person of color afterwards and just to
sit down and have this [ __ ] awesome
conversation about why they like the
joke and I'm like this is like if we
passed each other on the street it's
like we have no real reason to talk to
each other in depth about anything but
like if you get a joke and you see where
I'm coming from and you see that I'm
trying to understand where you're coming
from and then we could sit down and have
a conversation like that's the country's
so divided
but it's and I'm sorry to make that
noise so close on the microphone no it's
great we needed it how much about you
it's just needed and necessary
everyone's like oh the stand-up thing
everyone's getting into stand-up when's
the bubble gonna burst and I'm like as
long as that [ __ ] keeps happening like
it's important oh yeah I agree
especially when someone's willing like
it opens up conversation and dialogue
from like a respectful point of view
that you like you said if you pass them
on the street you wouldn't why would you
just tap someone on the shoulder be like
I have something that I'd like to talk
to you yeah yeah and I think you're a
great kind of like tentpole of welcoming
conversation from a very sort of
optimistic point of view about like
finding mutual ground or finding common
ground in some way rather than just
being like no I have my opinion so yours
are completely invalid to me and yeah
not worth my time or energy to even like
brain about right now yeah well you're
stupid until you learned about chef
there you go and you hate [ __ ] while you
know if you're unfamiliar and scared
about it the more you can learn and
familiarize yourself with everything
it's like you become a well-rounded
person [ __ ]
[Laughter]
2010 everybody gets a book everyone
we're gonna be in an airport somewhere
dude I remember when I did my [ __ ] cuz I
was like one of the first people to do
that it when I would talk to people and
they would be like well why would anyone
buy this book from like a YouTube person
I was like watch and then I did a
Kickstarter thing I got filled up like
that I was like see now I keep on my own
money yeah and then all these companies
were like oh then we should do that yeah
and then people did that it was very
weird to remember Hannah did it and I
was like I think I'll try that yeah it
happens and then everyone had a book but
it's a fun challenge it's a very it's a
different muscle especially because I'm
I you didn't have a ghostwriter I didn't
have a ghostwriter so everything would I
don't wish I think I'd be like I don't
want to read the chapter that you sent
me yeah
like tell me the abridged version of
does it sound like I would sound like me
someone's no who's your favorite valley
folk member oh man Kevin oh I didn't
know we're talking about Talent yeah
Kevin for sure your ankles okay what
happened your ankle I don't want to talk
about it okay
1017 1017 they walked Zoe I started this
thing on our podcast we're me and her
we're playing basketball at the park and
we obviously do that anymore because of
this situation and we played against
like grandfather and his granddaughter
whoever's at the park wait you guys play
oh I thought you played one-on-one
against each other we weren't that's how
it started and then you started to
hustle people
yeah well we gotta make money this
fourteen-year-old like AAU girl came up
and she was like let's go player I was
like Zoe is wearing jeans so we're gonna
do so he played them and her grandfather
and I remember I was guarding her and
she did this thing she she like crossed
me up and then she goes ankles and you
can't do that when you don't really if
you don't make someone fall down and
can't yell and then I got super upset
and I think Zoya scratched her at one
point so it became a story where like
Mike got crossed up by this
fourteen-year-old girl in the park which
wasn't true and now it was just this
thing that people won't let go that's so
[ __ ] funny this is my that's my load
to bear when was the last time you guys
hustled at the park that's been a while
it's been a while okay well we'll get
you to ankle braces and get you back out
there thanks for jumping on the wrong
bandwagon
right that is so [ __ ] funny oh my god
someone what's your advice for someone
that wants to do stand-up but is
terrified of it we got a lot of those
kind of questions you just gotta do it I
mean it's the thing where it's like you
got to be okay with knowing that there's
so many times and stand-up that you
think you you have something figured out
yeah and you don't and you got to be
okay with that and it's like a lot of
people especially today and this is a
reason why I'm not like worried about my
job or think I'm in competition with
anyone ever it's because it takes so
long and it takes so much discipline and
trying and and sacrificing your own
personal time together
even halfway decent at it and you're do
you either have the mind to do that or
you don't
yeah and um it's like resilience
understanding that failure is not
complete that it's only like a stepping
stone cassettes I think my biggest fear
of is like if I fail I will be too hard
on myself to even try again yeah I think
a lot of people probably have that kind
of point of view about it
mm-hmm and I could see that it's a scary
thing it's all about like destroying
your as much of your ego as you possibly
can that's fair and being like oh like
you do this thing because you think
you're funny or your friends have been
like you should do stand
yeah yeah and then you don't want to do
that and be like oh I'm not funny like I
put myself in front of there's this
whole thing where like I was taught that
stand-up because it's in a cold room and
because it's in front of a brick wall
it's supposed to simulate an execution
and you get there and everyone's wants
to see if you'd if you kill or if you
get killed yeah you know and so you're
doing that every single time whoa
I've never heard that before that's how
I was taught Wow someone was the real
militia piece yeah you tell about the
old brother comedians are like this is
what it is do you want do you think
you're this funny okay last question
someone's don't ask him how he first
started using the term horny in everyday
conversation oh yeah player when you
scan through literally upwards of five
seconds yeah if you do like a command F
find this word on this page horny is a
maybe
you're most commonly-used yeah for sure
without question it's just first of all
it's the funniest word that there is and
it's also like a personal connection
with my home and the friends that I had
from my home my friend Jorge perm who is
an amazing artist that he has a tattoo
shop in Stratford Connecticut called
forest ashore okay he's like amazing it
doesn't give a [ __ ] about anything and
me and him used to say we'd be like
horny jacket and it's so it catches
people so off-guard
it's just the funniest it's it's it's
funnier to know exactly what you mean
and to wait for somebody else's reaction
yeah and then I say it's so casually
that people it's like it's like saying
cool cool cool yeah you look through the
Twitter feed me is what it is think
about like I don't know if you guys need
my text to Elliott Michelle and I used
to say tits in the mouth cool that's a
woman the same way yeah that was the
thing and we said it's so casually with
each other and like in videos and stuff
that I remember saying it like in group
settings and being like oh right that's
not a phrase that people use to say like
that's awesome that's actually meaning
to me and you see people like going
through their mental image of it yeah
yeah I guess skateboarding is kind of
[Laughter]
guess this yogurt is I love it
Mike thank you so much for being there
before you go every guess it's on our
podcast it's a personalized fortune
cookie from us to you perfect yep
smashes this has nothing in it
[Music]
[Laughter]
really good we need that handsome art
thank you who did this part that's I
Melissa
you gotta jam it in there somehow
Chinese don't we don't we don't we don't
know we haven't done our research you
use a higher a Chinese person okay okay
I'm not a great readers time I was in
the slow reading class which was in a
closet by the way they took the dumb
kids and they put us in a closet do you
write your words too close together get
my closet I didn't learn about dyslexia
until I was like 27 in a closet okay you
may say you're not Jesus but we've also
never seen you two in the same room so I
have a joke about this day and I say I
look like the version of Jesus that
white people hope there is and you see
me and I'm just like hey you were fine
I've been up here for a while
I know supposed to come back I just
haven't set my alarm to okay Mike where
can people find you online in person etc
etc um any word you could spell my name
I show up on the Internet
that's Mike Falzone apparently it sounds
like calzone I don't hear it um all over
LA all the time doing stand-up and then
I keep forgetting to shout out these
dates that I have with this might come
out after these dates but oh the Elliot
stuff is this coming out yeah after May
this may be out okay I have no other
chefs follow you on twitter and your
social media you promote your shows like
crazy and so everything's there for them
to follow and they can listen to dynamic
banter
and what's the podcast of Zoya welcome
to our podcast and then if you're more
of a YouTube person I do this show
called Mike in the morning which is like
a ridiculous morning show every Tuesday
and then yeah Tuesday and Friday I have
no videos come on sweet awesome thank
you we'll see you guys next time when
I'm episode not too deep goodbye 2deep
2deep 2deep 2deep again this episode of
not too deep has been brought to you by
one of my favorite companies say out
loud
aunt Fanny's for years we've known about
probiotics for our guts yet our cleaning
supplies are busy wiping out all the
good with the bad
so bring probiotic power to your home
with new microcosmic cleaners and hand
soaps from aunt Fanny's they add good
with a beneficial bacteria extract plus
safe plant-based cleaners they're tough
on dirt gentle on you shop aunt Fanny's
dot-com / good and use the coupon code
grace at checkout for 20% off your
entire order not too deep as a
production of grace helbig incorporated
producer and edited by melissa demons
writing by diane kang a production
assistants by Katrina Henning
post-production sound by Chris Henry and
an extra special thanks to Flula for the
theme music
[Music]